la chronique de l'écho claire Cambier
bonsoir et donc deux invités qui sont
venus sur ce plateau puisqu'il y a deux
jours quelques jours du Salon de
l'Agriculture on va s'intéresser aux
produits locaux ce soir exactement on
profite du Salon de l'Agriculture pour
aborder le sujet du produire et
consommer local il y a un véritable
engouement de nos jours pour déjà
consommmer français et au-delà dans le
domaine de la nourriture manger local
alors quel est l'intérêt au niveau
économique pour le producteur mais aussi
pour le consommateur peut-on tout
consommer local quelles sont les limites
c'est ce que nous allons découvrir avec
nos deux invités Gérard Richard qui est
responsable de la boutique gourmande à
la Bergerie Nationale de Rambouillet et
Benoît Dupré agriculteur donc à la ferme
de viltin à jouillan Josas alors tout
simplement déjà quel est l'intérêt pour
vous de vendre
local peut-être oui ben bonjour donc la
l'intérêt de vendre locale c'est c'est
déjà une grosse demande que que nous
avons de la part de nos clients
consommateurs qui deviennent
consoacteurs euh l'intérêt aussi c'est
de quand même valoriser les productions
des agriculteurs locaux et d'apporter
notre soutien et d'avoir des produits
qui font pas la moitié du tour du monde
avant d'arriver sur nos étalins alors
c'est ça en fait dans dans vos deux
boutiques vous avez aussi des aliments
en fait qui viennent d'autres
agriculteurs du coin c'est ça oui vous
pouvez nous expliquer un petit peu du
coup que vous r plus les les produits
qui sont issus de l'exploitation à
vilettin on est une ferme laitière donc
on fabrique des yaourts des fromages
blancs de la crème et cetera du lait les
gens viennent surtout d'abord pour nos
produits pour nos yaourts pour notre
lait et puis ben ils peuvent trouver des
tas de produits fermiers qui viennent
d'abord de notre région et puis après
des produits fermiers un petit peu de
toute la France et comme ça on peut
faire son marché complètement voilà le
but c'est de rassembler en fait les
différents produits qu'on peut trouver
dans dans notre département au même oui
notre département ou celui d'à côté
parce qu'on est pas on aime bien le 91
77 et cetera bien sûr tout un changement
d'attitude de la part du du consommateur
vous parliez de consommacteur justement
c'est c'est une formule qui qui marche
assez bien pour vendre justement mais
mais ça existe véritablement les gens
changent d'attitude ils veulent savoir
d'où viennent leurs produits qu'
viennent d'à côté de chez eux ah oui
tout à fait ça c'est la fréquentation
est en hausse par exemple la
fréquentation en haut c'est la la
spécificité des des produits qui qui
nous sont demandés et et voilà et
vraiment se reporte à des producteurs
locaux des productions locales ou ou
périphériquees parce que bien sûr il y a
des
producteurs qui sont qui viennent pas
forcément du 78 on a beaucoup de
producteurs dans le 28 dans le Perche
des choses comme ça mais sur la plaine
de Rambouillet on a on arrive à voir de
la céréale bio donc on a du pain bio on
a des producteurs de fromage de chèvrees
on a des producteurs de fromage de lait
de vache on a des des des maréchés nous
avons tout un tas de de choses comme ça
mar justement il y a aussi le système de
cuillette que vous avez mis en place euh
vous me disiez justement que la surface
de cueillette a grandi bah fur à mesure
que il y a eu de la demande ben on a
augmenté aussi le nombre de pass
d'hectares on est passé au départ en en
900 alors ça remonte quand même hein de
1980 on avait 3 hactares et puis
maintenant on a 50 hectares de
cueillette avec 50 produits qui vont des
fleurs les fruits les légumes les pommes
enfin c'est très varié et la cliente
comme ça a un énorme choix de seulement
évidemment pendant la période des
récoltes c'estàd du mois d'avril avec
les premières tulipes jusqu'au 11
novembre la fin des la cuueillette des
pommes alors justement la limite c'est
elle est peut-être là c'est la terre
finalement
oui c'est la terre et puis c'est surtout
la volonté qu'on peut avoir et ben de de
faire un autre métier qui est vraiment
celui d'agriculteur c'est celui de
transformateur de conditionneur et puis
de de distributeur ça c'est obligation
aujourd'hui cette évolution elle est
nécessaire justement ben je pense qu'il
y a une demande des de la population
justement de pouvoir consommer
localement d'avoir des produits d'à côté
de chez lui des produits d'un
agriculteur qui connaît parce qu'on
parle souvent des difficultés des
agriculteurs he sur le plan économique
elles sont réell et là de justement
modifier faire évoluer les les métiers
et savoir faire autre chose aussi c'est
une nécessité pour la survie des
exploitations par
exemple je pense que c'est une volonté
de c'est un autre métier hm hm donc euh
il faut avoir envie en plus d'être
agriculteur d'être aussi un un un un
transformateur un laitier un fromager
euh euh faire de la boucherie pour ceux
qui qui vont être amener à tuer leur
leurs animaux et cetera donc c'est un
autre métier mais c'est un métier qui
est passionnant et aussi c'est très
intéressant de pouvoir avoir sentir le
débouché de de de du produit d'origine
que l'on a qui est du lait tout simple
et puis de savoir que ça ça va être
transformé en yaourt je ve dire que
c'est ça lui donne une valeur ajoutée
bien sûr un gain supplémentaire que
vendre son lait directement à une
laiterie mais ça va aussi nous donner
beaucoup de fierté de dire que ça c'est
notre lait mais c'est aussi maintenant
un yaourt et on PIR le consommer
différemment et pour le consommateur
vous pensez c'est également la même
chose de savoir vraiment d'où vient mon
yaourt et ben bah de ces vaches-ci c'est
c'est ça l'intérêt vous pensez ou je
pense que oui c'est à côté de chez lui
il devient un acteur consommateur il
devient un acteur qui qui participe à la
vie économique euh il y a un lien de de
j'allais dire d'amitié mais presque qui
qui se fait entre entre le consommateur
alors ça c'est vrai pour tous nos
clients qui nous connaissent qui
viennent à la ferme et cetera mais
maintenant c'est nouveau euh c'est tout
le monde veut du produit local donc on
en veut aussi dans les cantines
scolaires on en veut dans les
restaurants d'entreprise on en veut
aussi dans son hôtel et vous avez eu des
hausses de des demandes en voilà des
restaurant d'entreprise également
exactement les restaurants
d'entreprisees veulent des produits de
viltin les cantines scolaires veulent
des produits V c'est Tron pour votre
chiffre d'affair alors et ben c'est très
bon pour qu est la progression de ces
dernières années par qu'on est dans la
page de l'cho alors forcément on a une
très bonne progression intéressante en
tout cas qui demande qui demande à qui
demande à être concrétisé encore
évidemment parce que c'est c'est le
début les premiers c'est les mais des
demandes tous les jours alors évidemment
ça demande des organisations évidemment
de distribution mais mais on fait tout
pour pour le mettre en place chiffre
d'affaires aussi en ha en ce qui vous
concerne avec ces demandes qui
augmentent oui c'est les le chiffre
d'affaires donc sur la boutique
gourmande de la Bergerie Nationale donc
nous nous avons la spécificité de
commercialiser entre autres les produits
locaux régionaux de de partenaires parce
que les les agriculteurs locaux c'est
quand même plus des partenaires que des
fournisseurs nous on commercialise les
produits fabriqués par les différents
lycées agricoles donc nous avons 40
lycées agricoles qui sont adhérents donc
n commercial alisons les vins les les
les fromages les produits de charcuterie
les conserves d'une quarantaine de
lycées agricoes mais c'est vrai que les
les partenaires les agriculteurs sont
fiers et c'est vrai ils sont fiers de de
présenter leurs produits on travaille
avec de la viande bovvine de de
Rambouillet on travaille aussi voilà les
les agriculteurs sont vraiment fiers de
de présenter leurs produits ça voilà et
les clients sont contents de savoir que
ça vient de d'à côté que ça vient de pas
loin que
que c'est préparé en petite quantité à
petite échelle alors le le le contrecout
c'est que bah c'est pas toujours
disponible nous on a des malheureusement
souvent des ruptures parce que nous nous
sommes uniquement revendeurs sur la
boutique gourmande bah ça se limite B au
nombre de caisses de viande qu'on peut
faire dans un veau nombre de caisses de
viande qu'on peut faire dans un beau vin
qu'on a peut-être untit peu oublié au
fur à mesure amarchés h ce qu'on a c'est
qu'il y a pas toujours tout tout le
temps bon bah on se fournit en primeur
aussi sur le lycée de Saint-Germain bah
quand il y a plus la saison de pomm et
ben on a plus de pomm c'est vrai que ça
c'est un problème faut réhabituer les
gens à ne pas avoir tout tout le temps
en quantité en quantité importante et
disponible en
permanenceement CLI peut-être
s'intéresser à ce qu'il pensent les
clients exactement on a poser la la
question donc au aux habitants pour
savoir est-ce que finalement vous
consommez local on regarde ça c'est très
important pour moi cela je regarde même
de façon très précise la provenance de
tous les produits que je consomme pas
nécessairement non bon je cherche pas
forcément des produits locaux ouais très
très
important surtout enfin surtout ici quoi
aider les producteurs oui très important
oui oui pour l'écologie tout ça pour
pour éviter d'avoir des trop de frais de
transport et la pollution absolument des
produits des produits français oui des
produits plus régionaux mais s'il y
avait encore plus près je prendrais hein
oui 100% et ça évite comment dire les
tout ce qui est pollution tout ce qui
est puis c'est bien de faire vivre nos
petits producteurs à côté quoi plutôt
que d'aller chercher en Espagne par
exemple où effectivement c'est beaucoup
moins cher mais c'est pas la même
qualité non plus
quoi alors pas la même qualité c'est
finalement ce que les consommateurs
recherchent euh donc on voit il y a de
plus en plus de ventes locales ce qui
pose finalement problème c'est peut-être
la transformation vous l'vquz déjà un
petit peu tout à l'heure ou c'est un
autre métier hein donc il faut se mettre
faut se mettre dans un dans faut être
agriculteur mais aussi être fromagé
savoir que ça va se faire dans un
atelier qui va être au norm on fait pas
ça dans sa
cuisine faut avoir l'envie et puis
finalement il y a aussi des raisons
économiques on s'est rendu donc à la
Bergerie Nationale de Rambouillet on y a
rencontré le directeur de l'exploitation
et on a vu justement qu'il y avait
parfois quelques limites on va regarder
le
sujet La Bergerie Nationale de
Rambouillet 220 hectares de culture 600
moutons des vaches des poules ou encore
des chèvres mais quel chemin un
parcours-il jusqu'à nos assiettes comme
beaucoup de producteurs des Yvelines la
Bergerie Nationale favorise les circuits
courts c'est-à-dire un seul
intermédiaire voire même aucun entre le
producteur et le consommateur c'est
positif au niveau économique puisque on
arrive à valoriser davantage surtout si
on transforme avant le le produit et
puis ben c'est vrai que on a une
sensibilité développement durable sur le
site de la bergerie et le le fait de de
vendre en local qu' ait moins de
transport i pour les productions ben
c'est quelque chose qui compte également
pour nous pour faire plus de marge et un
geste pour la planète les lieux de
revendes sont donc exclusivement en
île-de-fance le circuit le plus court la
boutique gourmande à la bergerie même
qui regroupe aussi des produits des
fermes alentours en première ligne les
œufs et la viande d'agneau consommer
local c'est donc possible et même ces
vaches comme tous les animaux de cette
ferme se nourrissent du fourrage cultivé
sur place mais alors peut-on tout
produire et som localement il y a des
régions qui sont qui ont un potentiel
agronomique et un nombre de produits
très grand donc tant mieux pour eux les
consommateurs peuvent bénéficier d'un
maximum de choses par contre quand on a
des régions beaucoup plus spécialisé AC
des sols beaucoup plus spécifique donc
des productions plus spécialisé derrière
il faut se limiter à ce qui est produit
localement quoi voilà c'est un petit peu
la limite une autre limite la
transformation si on prend l'exemple des
agnaux les agnaux sont produits la erie
vendu à l'Intermarché de
Rambouillet mais entreetemps ils sont
abattus dans des abattoirs agréé donc
l'abattoir agréé le plus proche
aujourd'hui c'est nosan le retrou donc
il faut quand même compter une heure de
route et on a entendu parler cette
semaine que cet abattoir risquait de
fermer et donc dans ce cas-là les
animaux seraient abattus en Bretagne
pour être rentable les abattoirs doivent
donc faire plus de volume des abattoirs
plus gros mais du coup moins nombreux et
plus éloignés un frein évident au
circuit
court alors un frein au circuit court
donc c'est ce problème de cet abattoir
qui va peut-être fermer finalement c'est
moins d'abattoir parce c'est pour une
économie d'échelle oui ça c'est vrai
qu'on on déplore le fait que bah tous
les abattoirs municipaux ferment les uns
après les autres les les normes
européennes drastiques font que les
catégories d'agrément diminu et c'est
économiquement il devient très difficile
de pouvoir conserver ces petits outils
de production
d'abattage en état donc c'est vrai bah
il va falloir faire à nos animaux il
faut que pour correspondre au règlement
de l'Union européenne être toujours plus
à jour se mettre à jour et ça demande
des investissements voilà c'est ça alors
on demande on demande aux petits
abattoirs qui vont abattre quelques
centaines d'animaux les mêmes normes et
les mêmes configurations techniques que
les abattoires qui abattent des milliers
d'animaux donc c'est vrai que pour les
agriculteurs locaux c'est c'est un frein
extraordinaire un surcoup et et une
aberration une gabg de de faire faire
500 km à à un animal vivant et ramener
la carcasse pour le transformer et la
commercialiser dans nos dans nos
ateliers dans nos boutiques quoi et ça
c'est vraiment un frein extraordinaire
et Ben et puis une perte de repère pour
les consommateurs parce que après il
voit sur les stampilles sanitaires que
Bretagne final voilà on arrive on arrive
sur des départements que ils disent non
on s'assaute trois départements qure
départements et là ils comprennent plus
comment on peut faire produire local en
allant abattre des animaux jusqu'en
Bretagne quoi benpr vous connaissez vous
allez peut-être connaître le même
problème puisque vous avez une
coopérative pour votre laie en carne et
là elle est elle est un peu menacée de
fermeture elle connait des difficultés
en tout cas oui nous déjà à la ferme on
a une laiterie où sur place on fabrique
du lait et on fabrique aussi des
fromages blancs et il y a une partie de
de nos fabrications de yaourt qui se
trouve en effet en scarne on a fait une
coopérative et pourquoi on fait une
coopérative parce qu'on a besoin d'être
de faire des gros volumes des gros
volumes pour aussi pouvoir absorber ce
que nous demande par exemple acheter des
pots de yaourt faut les acheter minimum
par 200000 vous voyez bien que c'est pas
à viltin au niveau du seulement qu'on
peut acheter 200000 po donc un appel a
été lancé sur internet il faut sauver
parilet alors parilet oui c'est c'est la
laiterie avec lequel on travaille ils
ont un cahier des chargge c'est nous qui
leur fournissons le lait le lait par de
viltin deux fois par semaine et avec ces
dans cettees lrique sont fabriqué une
partie de nos fabrications mais des des
fabrications aussi qui sont vendu en
local ici en région parisienne
pour conclure je suis désolée on va
rapidement voir votre présence au salon
d'agriculture oui c'était le pourquoi de
votre venue euh vous allez y présenter
des produits oui donc bah la bergerie
sera présente avec le les œufs
principalement les œufs sur le r 7 et
pour présenter bah toutes ces animations
parce qu'il faut savoir aussi que la
bergerie c'est une grande ferme
pédagogique donc nous recevons quand
même 90000 visiteurs à l'année dont
70000 enfants qui viennent soit avec
leurs parents ou alors en bus en voyage
de fin d'année ou en classe de
découverte et voilà en atelier
pédagogique sur le lait les céréales les
choses comme ça donc la bergerie sera en
force au salon de l'agriculture allall 7
pour présenter toutes ses animations et
puis commce aliser ses œufs bio et
vousmême vous donc à Vard dans le hall 3
ça fait 20 ans que on est présent au
salon de l'agriculture c'est une façon
aussi de se faire connaître de de dire
aux clients que ben on est qu'à 17 km de
Paris et puis on est présent aussi au
salon de l'agriculture parce que c'est
nous qui nourrissons les vaches du salon
tous les matins il y a 5 tonnes de de
fourrage de viltin qui sont en camion
amené en camion à au salon pour nourrir
les vaches et ça fait quand même
quelques années que vous le faites oui
aussi merci donc à tous les deux on va
poursuivre cette chronique de l'écho
clair avec les infos en plus de ce soir
et oui alors première info c'est la
création du premier label francilien
pour les restaurateurs on parlait de
consommation locale cette tendance est
également vraie pour les restaurateurs
un nouveau label a été lancé le 19
février des produits d'ici cuisiné ici
il est destiné à mettre en valeur les
chefs franciliens qui cuisinent des
produits d'Île- de- France 50 chefs ont
donc été labellisé dont deux dans les
ivelines il s'agit du clou de Chevreuse
à Chevreuse donc elle du monument café à
Versailles on passe à Virgine à présent
autre information concerne la
consommation grand publique les magasins
vont être vendus exactement le plan de
continuation conçu par Virgine Virgine a
été refusé lors du comité d'entreprise
hier les 26 magasins dans toute la
France vont être vendus parmi eux celui
de Montini qui emploie une quarantaine
de salariés un appel d'offre sera lancé
demain dernière date pour les éventuels
repreneurs le 5 avril ou pour se faire
connaître et puis cette dernière
information en plus une convention pour
l'emploi espace Saint-Quentin une bonne
nouvelle oui pour l'emploi une
convention de partenariat vient d'être
signé entre Pôle Emploi donc et le
centre commercial de Montini l'espace
Saint-Quentin son but est de mettre en
place un plan d'action pour mieux cibler
les offres d'emploi et les demandes des
boutiques l'enjeu est important puisque
l'espace Saint-Quentin compte 130
boutiques en tout 1500 personnes
travaillent sur les deux centres on
écoute Hervé d' niot pour nous présenter
cette convention de partenariat
faciliter à la fois ceux qui recherchent
un emploi et faciliter les employeurs
c'està-dire les enseignes on va en fait
pôemploi fait anticipe les besoins
qualifie également le profil de poste
recherché et ce qui permet déjà de faire
une présélection de candidat donc c'est
à la fois bénéfique pour le candidat et
à la fois pour l'employeur c'est-à-dire
que le Pôle emploi en fait fait
régulièrement des visites des enseignes
pour connaître leurs besoins anticiper
également les demandes en
traditionnellement classique sur les
pics de commercial c'estàd les soldes et
puis Noël et donc en fait ils ont un
prélisting de des des besoins et après
en fait ils vont faire une présélection
des candidats et les proposer aux
enseignant si vous vous connectez sur le
site Espace 51 centre commercial dans la
démarche citoyen que dont s'inscrit le
centre commercial vous cliquez vous avez
les offres d'emploi et vous êtes renvoyé
directement sur le Pôle emploi sur 2012
en fait on a on a fait 150 offres on a
pourvoyé à 150 offres d'emploi rien que
sur le centre commercial l'espace 5qu1
58 % sur ce qui est restauration métier
de bouche et et servicees après on a 35
% sur sur le prête àortter et après sur
les métiers de service qui demandent un
petit peu plus de qualification comme la
coiffure ou l'optique par exemple on est
plutôt sur un petit peu moins de 10 %.
et pour finir jusqu'au 23 février c'est
encore la Semaine de l'emploi on vous en
parlait la semaine dernière mercredi la
Mission Locale organiser un jeu de
l'emploi une sous forme donc de grands
jeu de loi on regarde ge le sujet
ensemble comment s'appelle la période
durant laquelle l'employeur et le
salarié peuvent rompre le contrat à tout
moment la période dés ouais c'est votre
réponse
ouais c'est gagné pour Hervé et son
équipe leur pion géant va pouvoir
avancer de quelques cases à la Mission
Locale de Guill en cour on joue au jeu
de loi grandeur nature des questions des
mimes ou encore des cartes surprises
autour du thème du monde du travail un
moyen ludique pour participer à la
semaine de l'emploi et apprendre d'une
manière bien différente qu'une classique
leçon en classe en jouant ça nous permet
de mieux retenir en fait que en cours
parce que enfin les courses c'est les
cours quoi donc toute la journée de
mercredi des jeunes suivis par la
Mission locale se sont succédés autour
du plateau et vu l'ambiance ils ont bien
accroché à ce jeu de l'emploi ça m'amuse
j'aime bien intéressant on apprend des
trucs qu'on connaissait pas des trucs
comme le poids des charges patronales ou
encore la durée maximum légale du temps
de travail en période de crise on avait
envie d'aborder le l'emploi avec les
jeunes de manière différente et on
voulait les aider à apprendre des bases
de l'emploi du droit du travail des
abréviations de base que les jeunes
connaissent pas forcément et on voulait
les aider à les apprendre euh de manière
ludique aider à apprendre pour bien
s'orienter et affronter le marché du
travail chaque année la Mission Locale
de Saint-Quentin en Yveline accompagne
près de 3500 jeunes de 16 à 25
ans et la chronique de l'écho qui se
termine par quelques dates c'est
l'agenda de cette chronique exactement
alors samedi plusieurs portes ouvertes
auront lieu pour ceux qui sont
intéressés par les métiers du cinéma ou
de l'audiovisuel les trois is l'Institut
international images et son les accueils
samedi de 10h à 18h dans leur locaux à
hencour et puis une grande partie de
l'Université de Saint-Quentin en iveline
ouvrira également ses portes ce samedi
ce sera de 14h à 17h30 et seront
présentés l'UFR des Sciences Sociales
l'Institut des études culturelles
l'Institut supérieur de management celui
des langues et des études
internationales et enfin l'observatoire
de Versailles Saint-Quentin iveline vous
pourrez retrouver le programme sur le
site de
l'université ensuite les rencontres
créatives qui se dérouleront mardi 26
février une journée complte organisé par
l'association d'entrepreneurs au féminin
Créactive à partir de 9h30 des retours
d'expérience des conférences sur le
management la création d'entreprises ou
encore les stratégies commerciales se
déroulera à promo pool à Montini et puis
on rappelle évidemment les dates du
salon de l'agriculture il débute samedi
et vous pouvez vous y rendre jusqu'au 3
mars à la Porte de Versailles à Paris
c'est donc tous les jours de 9h à 19h
avec une nocturne à noté vendredi 1er
mars jusqu'à à 23h et puis pour fêter
les 50 ans de cet événement
international la mascotte cette année
n'est pas la traditionnelle vache les
organisateurs ont choisit comme emblème
SEP animaux dont Lorenzo un mouton
merinos qui nous vient de la Bergerie
Nationale de Rambouillet merci Claire
pour cette page de l'économie justement
ce Beller Merino Lorenzo qui vient de
votre Brégerie d'ailleurs et ben nous
sommes allés le rencontrer portrait
signé de la rédaction Julie Rocha et le
dis Mo vous allez voir il a du
caractère Lorenzo magnifique bélier de
race de rambouiller se prépare pour le
Salon de l'Agriculture dès samedi et
durant 9 jours ce mâle de 4 ans quittera
la Bergerie Nationale pour représenter
les ovins pour faire honneur à sa race
importé d'Espagne en
1786 il a eu droit à un soin particulier
la traditionnelle taille des onglons
comprendre Séan de manucure et pédicure
et une tonte au mois d'août afin de
présenter une toison de 6 mois
irréprochable pour l'anecdote Lorenzo
qui tient son prénom d'un berger
retraité de la bergerie national produit
l'équivalent de 9000 km de fibre de
laine chaque année le manteau qu'on lui
fait porter depuis le jours de sa tonde
c'est ça fait 6 mois à peu près a pour
but de d'éviter que des impuretés
viennent salir sa toison notamment la
poussière mais aussi toutes les
impuretés végétales le foin la paille
puisque il est il vit en bergerie donc
il y a forcément des des impuretés qui
pourrai venir souiller la toison le
travail des bergers s'est aussi porté
sur le comportement de z le mouton est
un animal grégère habitué à vivre en
communauté pour parader au salon il a
donc découvert les balades en solitaire
et en laisse les premières sorties en
dehors du groupe ben pose souvent des
problèmes parce queanimal est s'inquiète
un peu bon faut l'habituer après on peut
pas être très familier avec un un bélier
parce que il vient très
vite très vite assez Cabo assez Técu
avec avec ses 85 kg Lorenzo a beauorté
le prénom d'un humain il n'en reste pas
moins une bête de
caractère et cette dernière information
vous avez sans doute vous le savez sans
doute vendredi se déroule les Césars la
remise des prix au 7e Mar pour la 3e
année consécutive l'Institut de
Formation 3IS à 50 ans en Yveline et
partenaire institutionnel les étudiants
avec leurs professeurs qui vont réaliser
des interviews et puis des making off
également pour l'Académie des Arts et
Techniques du Cinéma qui organise les
César fin du 78 pour ce jeudi demain
vous avez rendez-vous avec Catherine
zulato pour l'édition du weekend je vous
retrouve lundi en direct à 18h
excellente soirée sur notre
antenne